now
listen man I don't know if it's gonna
happen to you tonight get in there and I
just gotta be straight with you I want
you to know I appreciate what you
clearly cleaned up tonight I appreciate
that you put on that nice shirt it's a
it's a smooth shirt the fur clearly
clearly brushed it I want you to know
that I see that I appreciate that I
appreciate the fact that you're a huge
ass cat and you just like not letting
that stop you you like okay I'm still
gonna go wild friday night I need some
people socialize they can do some do
some dance I don't even I've never seen
a cat dance before I don't know what
that looks like maybe prance prance
around all nimbly sneak up on people
without them without him hearing you
[__] no maybe like you stopped praying
surround BP like Oh form a circle form a
circle this cat is dancing I would one
time I picked up my cat by the shoulders
and I picked him up off the floor so its
feet with dangling and I moved him to
and fro to the beat so it appeared as
though it was dance but he wasn't really
wasn't really dancing on his own free
will so I don't know I don't think you
want so you're too big you're too big to
have anyone do that anyway so
you know I gotta let in ladies I gotta
let it do it's a little bit fierce I
gotta let it VIPs I don't I don't have
anything on the clipboard by what I'm
supposed to do when there's like a huge
a scatman and a collared shirt tonight
you know my cat pebbles my cat walks
around but ass naked and before tonight
I never really had a problem with that
but I gotta I gotta be on you now I'm
considering buying him a tiny pair of
pants because now the nudity factor is
is on the table it's right out there so
I don't know I don't know what you would
think you could do anyway and get in
there see some ladies buying drinks go
home what taking back the old place for
some heavy petting that it some some
light to heavy petting yeah scratch
behind your ear you kinky your kinky son
button I'm with you dog cat you would
you look at all right but cat seriously
though do you sleep with women
you